we're going to begin with the last
ukrainian holdouts against a russian
offensive in a crucial city in southern
ukraine russia has shared this video of
smoke rising from a steel works in
mariupol where it's estimated thousands
of ukrainians troops and civilians are
under siege russia bombed the facility
overnight but it is vast and strongly
fortified the rest of mariupol has more
or less been destroyed most russian
forces are now pivoting to a new phase
of this war in ukraine when all-out
offensive in the east of the country
charlie dagger is in ukraine with more
on this story charlie good morning to
you
good morning to you gail another
ultimatum another deadline for ukrainian
forces to surrender in mary opal has
just come and gone both sides have
agreed on a humanitarian corridor to
allow civilians to leave but fighting
rages on in cities in the south and the
east
drone footage shows a city torn apart
after weeks of bombardment residential
neighborhoods flattened beneath the azov
stall iron and steel works plant women
and children huddled together in bomb
shelters too terrified to attempt an
escape
a ukrainian marine makes a desperate
plea we're facing our last days if not
last hours the enemy outnumbers us 10 to
1.
and the enemy is closing in fast russian
soldiers surround the steel plant
hunting down remaining fighters
russia has intensified attacks along a
500-mile front line advancing forward
and reinforcing regions already under
occupation including the hard-fought
zapariza nuclear facility europe's
largest
the nuclear power plant remains under
russian control in russian-held
territory on that side of the river this
is ukrainian-held territory nearby
they've been counting the cost of the
war
a russian anti-tank mine took the life
of 29-year-old paratrooper
demoth on saturday how important was it
for your son to fight for his country
it was very important he dreamed like
crazy becoming a soldier his mother
allah said
but i didn't bring him into this world
for war but for a peaceful life so he
could live with his beloved wife ivana
his beloved wife ivana and he had only
been married for 18 months they were
planning to start a family when the war
broke out the 23 year old widow told us
about their last video call saying she
knew that every call might be the last
one
every time we spoke i told him i love
you look after yourself she said
now i say i love you look after me
ivana told us when she first heard the
news she didn't want to believe it was
true but when it sunk in her world
shattered like a jigsaw puzzle
vlad
unimaginable and heartbreaking charlie
dagda in ukraine for us thank you
charlie